elle est pour l'instant la seule dans
les yvelines la première usine de
biométhanisation est à thoiry mais elle
pourrait bientôt avoir des petites
soeurs grdf et la chambre d'agriculture
d'île de france viennent de signer un
partenariat
alors cette convention va permettre
d'accompagner vous déjà déstructuré une
filière avec un différend nombre
d'acteurs d'opérateurs sur le sujet
méthanisation depuis les exploitants
agricoles à des porteurs de projets mais
aussi développer de nouveaux projets
faire émerger de nouveaux projets donc
ça va être à la fois de la pédagogie
l'accompagnement de porteurs de projets
jusqu'à la mise en relation et des
porteurs de projets entre cette usine
produira du gaz vers d'ici la fin du
premier trimestre 2010 8 une énergie
possible grâce aux fumées animale du zoo
mais aussi les déchets des exploitations
agricoles alentours la production de gaz
et récupérer elle est purifiée par
l'équipe manquait juste derrière moi
pour être injectée dans le réseau de gaz
grdf et le fumier lui du fait du temps
de séjour de 21 jours donc dans ce
digesteur à être digérée par les
bactéries et ben le fumier et les
déchets verts et les fruits et légumes
invendus et cetera tout ça ça forme un
digestat c'est comme du compost c'est
très qualitatif et ça fait un engrais
écologique pour les cultures agricoles
d'un point de vue technique ce gaz
naturel renouvelable est totalement
assimilable au gaz naturel qui est des
réseaux et d'ailleurs quand on injectera
ce gaz renouvelables il sera associé de
garantie d'origine un petit marqueur qui
fera en sorte de d'identifier qu'il
s'agit bien d'un gaz renouvelables et
non pas d'un gars aussi près de 2000
foyers sur huit communes seront ainsi
alimenter grdf souhaite atteindre 30 %
de gaz vers dans ses réseaux français
d'ici 2030